نبدا من التصعيد في المسجد الاقصى حيث
اقتحمت قوه من الشرطه الاسرائيليه صباح
اليوم صحه المسجد لتامين اقتحامات
المستوطنين لساحات الحرم القدسي في رابع
يوم من عيد الفصح اليهودي وجاءت الاقتحمات
على شكل مجموعات تحت حراسه مشدده من
الشرطه وادى المستوطنون طقوسا يهوديه فيما
تسود حاله من التوتر اجواء البلده القديمه
وفي هذه الاثناء كشفت وكاله الانباء
الفلسطينيه عن قيام الجيش الاسرائيلي
بتحويل باحات المسجد الاقصى الى ثكنه
عسكريه لتامين اقتحامات المستوطنين لساحات
الحرم وقد نصبت القوات الاسرائيليه حواجز
او الحواجز داخل اسوار البلده القديمه
وافراغ شوارعها من الماره وافادت مراسله
العربيه في القدس باقتحام 276 مستوطنا على
سته مجموعات الى اقتحامهم الاقصى حتى
الساعه السابعه صباحا
مشاهدينا من القدس مراسله العربيه لنا
كلاصي اهلا بك يا لانا معنا لانا كيف تبدو
الاوضاع الان في الحرم القدسي الشريف
اهلا بك فعليا توتر حاد وتوتر كبير جدا في
ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك منذ ساعات
الصباح كان هناك اقتحامات لاعداد كبيره من
المستوطنين حتى ارتفع الاعداد الى اكثر من
350 مستوطن باعمار مختلفه قاموا باقتحام
المسجد الاقصى او ساحات المسجد الاقصى
بحمايه مشدده من القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تتواجد حاليا في باحات المسجد الاقصى
اضافه الى يعني تواجد كبير لحواجز ايضا
التي نصابتها القوات الاسرائيليه على
ابواب المسجد الاقصى اضافه لذلك كان هناك
توتر فجر اليوم حيث قامت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه ايضا بمنع اعداد كبيره من
الفلسطينيين من دخول المسجد الاقصى لاداء
صلاه الفجر ولكن يعني كان هناك ايضا اعداد
من الفلسطينيين الذين
قاموا باداء صلاه الفجر خارج ساحات المسجد
الاقصى اي خارج
القدس اين تحدث عن توترات ما زالت متواجده
ايضا
برغبه بنك فير وهو وزير الامن القومي حيث
صرح وقال يجب على المستوطنين ان يذهبوا
ويقتحموا المسجد الاقصى فهذا المسجد هو
ليس فقط للمسلمين انما ايضا لليهود ويجب
على
اليهود فعليا ان يقوموا بالاقتحام في عيد
الفصح اليهودي ما نفهم من كلام بنكير هو
انه يحاول تغيير الامر الواقع المتواجد
حاليا في المسجد الاقصى ويريد ان يقوم
بتقسيم الزماني والمكاني للمسجد الاقصى ان
يكون هناك ايضا الجزء
لاسرائيليين والمستوطنين في المسجد الاقصى
نعم وطبعا هذا سيرجح تصاعد ربما التوتر في
القدس وفي الحرم القدسيه الشريف ايضا في
الساعات القادمه لانا كان هناك حديث
وانباء تتحدث عن انه اسرائيل الغت الكثير
من التصاريح وزادت من اجراءات المنع
للفلسطينيين من الدخول المسجد الاقصى
والصلاه في خلال هذه الايام حدثينا اكثر
عن هذه النقطه
صحيح في الجمعه الاولى والثانيه حسب
الادعاء الاسرائيلي كان هناك بعض
التسهيلات اي ان اعمار كبار السن كان هناك
اعداد منهم يستطيعون ان يجتازوا الحواجز
الاسرائيليه والدخول من الضفه للصلاه في
المسجد الاقصى ايام الجمعه ولكن ليله امس
كانت الجمعه الثالثه او عفوا قبل يومين
كانت الجمعه الثالثه من شهر رمضان التي
تزامنت ايضا مع الاعياد اليهوديه حيث قامت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه بالاعلام عن اغلاق
جميع الحواجز الاسرائيليه بين الضفه
الغربيه واسرائيل اي انه منع بشكل كلي
جميع الفلسطينيين من الدخول من الضفه
الغربيه الى اسرائيل لاداء صلاه الجمعه من
الجمعه الثالثه فقط اهل يعني سكان القد
الذين يستطيعون الوصول فقط الان
صحيح وايضا اعداد من الداخل كان هناك
اعداد من المدن والقرى الفلسطينيه من
اراضي الثمانيه واربعين الذين حضروا في
حافلات عديده فعليا ولكن الاعداد المصلين
شهدنا انخفاض كبير حيث يعني شاهدنا في
الجمعه الثانيه ربع مليون مصلي ولكن في
الجمعه الثالثه كان هناك فقط 130 الف مصلن
يعني نحن نشهد انخفاض كبير في هذه الاعداء
ايضا كان هناك من المفترض ان يكون اليوم
يتم يعني السماح او فك هذا القيد عن الضفه
الغربيه ولكن بسبب التوترات الامنيه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وزير الدفاع جلد قرر بتمديد هذا الاغلاق
على الضفه الغربيه وقرر بالغاء هذه
التسهيلات اضافه الى منع العمال من قطاع
غزه الدخول الى اسرائيل لاداء اعمالهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخ باريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات